Nummer 3 war es 2005 ist es dann in
Kraft getreten und das war eine
Zerreißprobe eine Durststrecke danach
für die SPD die immer wieder gemessen
wurde an diesen Maßnahmen an der
Zusammenlegung von Arbeitslosen und
Sozialhilfe dann 2019 gab es das erste
die das erste Papier dieses wie es bei
der SPD immer hieß Hartz IV zu
überwinden ein bürgergeldkonzept von der
damaligen Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Andrea Nahles
bekämpft wurde Hartz IV massiv von der
Linken die dadurch viel Gewinn gesogen
hat irgendwie aber was auch einer der
gründungsgründe gewesen ist für die
Zusammenlegung von wer oder das fürs
Zusammengehen von whsg und
Linkspartei.PDS und jetzt sind wir so
weit fast 20 Jahre nach der
Verabschiedung das tatsächlich die erste
Beratung stattfindet zum Bürgergeld und
wir werden gleich eine Debatte hören die
uns 90 Minuten lang ist wir haben 15
Minuten Zeit um schon mal auf ein paar
Kernpunkte zu gucken und ich freue mich
dass heute morgen bei uns sind Jessica
tatti aus der Linksfraktion wo sie
Arbeits sozialpolitische Sprecherin ist
und Martin Rosemann ist bei uns aus der
SPD-Fraktion Sprecher für Arbeit und
Soziales ganz witzig haben wir im
Vorfeld nicht gewusst ihre Wahlkreise
liegen gerade mal zehn Kilometer
auseinander etwas mehr vielleicht
immerhin so daher kennen sie sich unter
anderem deshalb ja auch ganz gut ich
fange mal bei Herrn Rosemann an das
Bürgergeld so heißt es im
Koalitionsvertrag soll die Würde der
oder des Einzelnen achten das lässt den
Umkehrschluss zu dass das bei ALG2 bei
Hartz IV nicht der Fall gewesen ist
zumindest hatten viele den Eindruck vor
allem solche Leute die sich angestrengt
haben die sich bemüht haben und trotzdem
mit der
sanktionseindrohung konfrontiert worden
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir auf
der einen Seite Mitwirkungspflichten
beibehalten und auch Leute die sich
verweigern dieser Mitwirkung auch
weiterhin mit Sanktionen rechnen müssen
aber dass wir diejenigen die sich
wirklich anstrengen und bemühen und
mitwirken dass die nicht ständig mit der
sanktionskeule bedroht werden das heißt
aber doch Hartz IV dann unterm Strich
etwas grenzwertig aus heutiger Sicht und
was die Würde des Einzelnen eingehen
es sind im Laufe der Jahre Fehler
gemacht worden auch bei dieser Reform
aber ich glaube wichtig ist vor allem
den Blick nach vorne zu richten denn wir
haben heute eine völlig andere
Arbeitsmarktlage als noch im Jahr 2003
oder 2005 wir hatten damals
Massenarbeitslosigkeit heute haben wir
Arbeitskräfte Mangel und deswegen müssen
wir die Instrumente der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik auf die Höhe der
Zeit bringen und das machen wir mit dem
Bürgergeld gucken wir auf einige Punkte
aus diesem Gesetzentwurf vielleicht noch
mal detailliert Frau tatti ich habe es
eben auch schon angesprochen Hartz IV
ALG2 war einer der gründungsgründe für
den Zusammenschluss von whsg und
Linkspartei geht den jetzt einer dieser
gründungsgründe auf Dauer verloren nein
das denke ich nicht weil wir haben jetzt
das zwölfte Änderungsgesetz von Hartz IV
und ich erkenne durchaus anders mit
diesem Gesetz erstmals auch einige
Verbesserungen auf den Weg gebracht
werden aber es ist aus meiner Sicht
keine Überwindung von Hartz IV wie das
ja seitens der
Regierungskoalition sowieso eine
Monstranz vor sich hergetragen wird wir
haben Euro Anpassung das ist aus meiner
Sicht keine echte Regelsatzerhöhung es
ist ja maximal ein Inflationsausgleich
der sowieso hätte kommen müssen laut
Verfassungsgericht also von daher kann
da von einer echten Erhöhung keine Rede
sein wir haben die Situation das
Hartz-IV-Empfänger auch heute am
wenigsten an Weiterbildungen teilnehmen
daran wird auch nichts geändert im
Gegenteil es wird werden ja noch mehrere
also 600 9 Millionen Euro im
Eingliederungstitel eingespart das
betrifft auch den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
der gerade für diejenigen die sonst
keine Arbeit finden können ein sehr
wichtiges Instrument ist also da wird
kaputt gespart und deshalb kann ich
nicht so ganz erkennen wo jetzt diese
wirkliche Abkehr von Hartz IV sein soll
guck mal was Martin Rosemann gleich dazu
sagte ich mir wollte tatsächlich mit dem
Regelsatz auch anfangen bei der
Betrachtung einzelner Punkte die Grünen
haben im Koalitionsvertrag oder im
Vorfeld dieses Gesetzentwurfs 100 Euro
mehr gewollt der Chef des Paritätischen
Wohlfahrtsverbandes Gesamtverbandes
Ulrich schn innerhalb von 200 gesprochen
warum reichen ihrer Meinung nach 50 Euro
Erhöhung aus für den Einzelnen
wir decken damit die massive
Preissteigerung ab die jetzt in den
letzten Monaten auch auf die
grundsicherungshaushalte zugekommen sind
und das ist ja zunächst mal wichtig wir
müssen schauen dass jetzt niemand
angesichts dieser Preissteigerungen
unter die Räder kommt das gilt für
Menschen mit geringen Löhnen und es gilt
für Menschen in der Grundsicherung und
da sind diese 50 Euro angemessen ich
glaube die 50 Euro sind schon
beschlossen worden vor diesem
eigentlichen inflationsgeschehen was ich
seit dem monatlichen ereigneter
Entlastungspaket beschlossen worden es
gab vorher keine Einigung in der
Koalition auf eine grundsätzliche
Regelsatzerhöhung der stand vorher war
dass der bisherige Mechanismus
weitergeht es wären ungefähr 20 Euro
gewesen
was halten Sie für nötig ja also es ist
wie gesagt die Leute bleiben so arm wie
vorher weil es eben maximal die
Preissteigerungen
ausgleicht und wir haben ja die
Situation dass die Leute standen hier
schon vor der kasseninflation mit dem
Rücken zur Wand finanziell und deshalb
sagt die Linke auch wir brauchen eine
Neuberechnung der Regelsätze und bis
dahin eben
200 Euro mehr im Monat damit auch
wirklich dass es wirklich den Leuten
auch finanziell besser geht und sie auch
den Kopf frei haben sich auf ihre
Arbeitsplatzsuche eine Weiterbildung
oder eine sonstige berufliche
Neuausrichtung vorzubereiten die ganze
Erhöhung wird jetzt schon erheblich
teurer als ursprünglich mal geplant war
wie würden Sie diese 200 Euro mehr denn
finanzieren wollen naja also ich meine
wir haben ja geht eine Regierung die
sagt es gibt mehr Beratung es gibt mehr
würde mehr Respekt und so weiter und wir
sehen das kaputt gespart wird also es
kann ja keine Rede davon sein
das müssen wir glaube ich mal ein
bisschen konkretisieren was sie mit
kaputt gespart eigentlich meinen na also
wir haben die Situation dass die
Jobcenter in diesem Haushalt 2023 eine
Milliarde weniger zur Verfügung haben
als sie brauchen ich weiß nicht wie sie
damit eine Beratung auf Augenhöhe
umsetzen können sollen wenn diese
Milliarde fehlt sie werden in die
eingliederungsmittel greifen müssen dass
der einzige Weg für die Jobcenter dann
ihre Verwaltung ihr Personal und so
weiter zu sichern und zusätzlich wird er
bei den eingliederungsmitteln selber
gespart bei Weiterbildungen beim
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt Minister Heil
hatte 150.000
Jobs im sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
versprochen in der letzten Legislatur
wir sind jetzt bei 40.000 das wird
weiter sinken und deshalb werden wir
auch noch mal einen Antrag einbringen
diese 150.000 zu finanzieren weil wir
denken dass es notwendig ist das Hartz
IV Empfänger auch eine Chance bekommen
wieder in Arbeit zu kommen er hat Frau
Tati rechter Rosemann
nein vor allem hat sie jetzt nichts dazu
gesagt wie sie 200 Euro mehr Regelsatz
finanzieren will und ich finde es schon
ganz interessant ich meine die Kritik
kommt jetzt von links es sei nicht genug
es sei zu wenig und die kritik kommt von
rechts wir würden das Lohnabstandsgebot
nicht einhalten und es würde sich nicht
mehr lohnen zu arbeiten was auch Unsinn
ist weil wir gleichzeitig zum ersten
Oktober den Mindestlohn auf 12 € erhöht
haben aber ich finde mal interessant
wenn man mit dieser Kritik von links und
mit rechts umgeht dann haben wir glaube
ich ziemlich viel an der Stelle richtig
gemacht und im Übrigen geht es ja bei
den Bürgergeld mir nicht nur um den
Regelsatz sondern es geht in der Tat
darum eine neue Kultur in den Jobcentern
zu leben es geht darum auf Augenhöhe zu
unterstützen es geht darum auch sehr
viel mehr auf nachhaltige Integration in
Arbeit zu setzen und deswegen ist es
falsch was Frau hat die gesagt hat zum
Thema Weiterbildung wir schaffen den
sogenannten vermittlungsvorgang ab der
bisher gesagt hat egal in Beschäftigung
das hat Vorrang vor Weiterbildung das
schaffen wir ab weil wir die Erfahrung
gemacht haben dass wir damit zu wenig
nachhaltige Investitionen bekommen aber
das ist ja der eigentliche Vorwurf den
macht dass sie nämlich sagt dass sie das
was sie jetzt gerade beschreiben die
Jobcenter gar nicht leisten können weil
da gespart worden ist
oder was Frau Tati verschweigt ist dass
die Aufstellung des Bundeshaushalts zu
einem Zeitpunkt passiert ist als das
bürgergeldgesetz noch gar nicht vorlag
das heißt der Bundeshaushalt
berücksichtigt das Bürgergeld noch gar
nicht und deswegen kann ich Frau Tati
beruhigen wir werden im
parlamentarischen Verfahren die
notwendigen Mittel für die Umsetzung des
Bürgergeldes bereitstellen als Koalition
Gegenrecht ist überhaupt nicht weil wenn
man doch weiß dass man das Bürgergeld
als Überwindung von Hartz IV wenn man
das vorgibt Hartz IV überwinden zu
wollen dann kürzt man doch nicht bei den
Jobcentern und dann kürzt man auch nicht
bei den eingliederungsmitteln wenn man
das ernsthaft vorhat und deshalb bleibe
ich dabei immer das heißt das was die
Koalition ja gesagt hat dass sie Hartz
IV überwinden will sie wie gesagt wir
machen den zwölftes Änderungsgesetz
sondern sie haben gesagt sie überwinden
Hartz IV und das wird da mit diesem
Gesetz so wie es im Moment vorliegt
nicht passieren sondern das Bürgergeld
bleibt Hartz IV Rosemann ja das ist
schlicht falsch also wir sind noch mal
sagen wir haben den Haushalt aufgestellt
da gab es noch kein bürgergeldgesetz und
das sind die parlamentarischen Abläufe
die könnte auch ratati kennen und
deswegen ist es so dass wir die dass wir
die Aufgaben des Bürgergeldes die werden
wir finanzieren das in den
parlamentarischen Beratungen
sicherstellen den Haushalt Frau Tati
macht am Ende der Deutsche Bundestag und
nicht die Bundesregierung dafür gibt es
ein Verfahren das ist völlig klar
die Jobcenter so auf ausstatten dass sie
das Bürgergeld auch umsetzen ob ihnen
das gefällt oder nicht und ihre ganze
oppositionsargumentation wird dann in
sich an der Stelle zusammenbrechen und
ich will es noch mal deutlich sagen
entscheidend mit diesem Bürgergeld ist
der Kulturwandel das ist eine
Unterstützung gibt auf Augenhöhe das
sanktionsandrohung nur noch für
diejenigen erfolgen die sich verweigern
und nicht mehr für die die mitwirken
dass es einen kooperationsplan gibt der
gemeinsam auf Augenhöhe vereinbart wird
wo die
Fähigkeiten die Interessen der
Leistungsberechtigten berücksichtigt
werden und dass wir sehr viel mehr auf
eine nachhaltige Integration durch
Weiterbildung setzen als das der Fall
war das ist die größte Sozialreform seit
vielen Jahren und das ist ein
Paradigmenwechsel und deswegen
lassen wir Hartz IV mit dieser Reform
hinter uns das mit dem Haushalt Frau
Tati wird sich in den kommenden Wochen
erst entscheiden in der Tat ich glaube
da wird kann auch einiges nachgelegt
werden da wird so einige Probleme geben
die die Koalition dann noch bekommt weil
einfach ja auch die Steuereinnahmen doch
deutlich niedriger sein werden als man
das ursprünglich mal vorgestellt hat und
alles jetzt hier natürlich durch die
Krise insgesamt und die Rezession die
sich andeutet ausgelöst es war von hier
von würde die Rede von Augen Höhe einen
Schlagwort was immer eine große Rolle
gespielt hat bei ALG2 und bei Hartz IV
war das Thema Sanktionen sehen sie da
Frau Tati die Koalition mit ihrem
Gesetzentwurf den sie heute das erste
mal hier ins Parlament einbringt auf
einem richtigen Weg natürlich ist es ein
richtiger Weg weil jetzt maximal noch 30
Prozent Sanktionen möglich sind das war
jetzt aber auch jetzt nicht eine
glorreiche Idee der Koalition sondern
ist die Umsetzung des
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil dass die
Sanktionen ja teilweise für
verfassungswidrig erklärt hat das war
2019 jetzt wird darauf auch gesetzlich
reagiert aber natürlich bleibt die Linke
auch da dabei das sozusagen dann eine
nachhaltige Integration in den
Arbeitsmarkt ein Arbeitsplatz mit dem
man seine finanzielle Situation wirklich
verbessern kann der beste Anreiz bleibt
für Arbeit und nicht die Sanktion und
dafür muss man auch prekäre Arbeit
bekämpfen ein Punkt wo sie beide
mutmaßlich einiger sind als bei den
bisherigen Punkten die wir besprochen
haben die Reaktionen aus der und
insbesondere auch aus der Unionsfraktion
da heißt es dann der des Bürgergeld so
wie es geplant ist jetzt von der
Koalition motiviere nicht zur
Arbeitssuche verringert den Abstand
zwischen bürgergeldempfänger und den
unteren Lohngruppen was er wieder dann
sie daher Rosemann ja das stimmt
schlichtig weil wir den Mindestlohn zum
1 Oktober auf 12 Euro erhöht haben
übrigens die CDU hat ja da nicht
mitgemacht sondern das haben wir gemacht
das Ampelkoalition maßgeblich die SPD
das war eines der zentralen Versprechen
von Olaf Scholz im Wahlkampf das haben
wir umgesetzt und damit bleibt
finanzielle Anreiz bestehen wir
verbessern sogar die
hinzuverdienstregelungen im neuen
Bürgergeld in dem ersten Schritt schon
mal wir werden das auch noch mal tiefer
gehende anpacken aber wir machen da
schon mal einen ersten Schritt wer
entlasten jetzt die ringverdiener bei
den Sozialabgaben indem wir die
midijobzone bis 2000 Euro ausweiten also
ich kann diese Kritik nicht
nachvollziehen und ich halte es sowieso
für ziemlich daneben jetzt die Ärmsten
gegen noch ärmer auszuspielen diese
Spaltung der Gesellschaft die hilft nun
wirklich nicht und das Bürgergeld wird
Mitwirkungspflichten vorsehen aber in
einem vernünftigen Rahmen und in dem
Rahmen den es Bundesverfassungsgericht
uns vorgegeben hat und wichtig ist dass
wir die Spreu vom Weizen trennen
diejenigen die sich bemühen die sich
anstrengen die mitwirken nicht mit
Sanktionen bedrohen und diejenigen die
sich verweigern ist sicherlich auch gibt
oder die sich durch Schwarzarbeit
entziehen dass die weiterhin auch mit
Sanktionen betonen diejenigen die
vielleicht nicht können weil sie
psychisch krank sind identifizieren und
die dann eben auch nicht in die
sektionsspirale reindrücken sondern den
zielgenau helfen das ist das der Gedanke
des Bürgergeldes ich glaube das ist
genau das was das Gerechtigkeitsgefühl
den Menschen auch entspricht und was
auch den einzelnen gerecht wird sie
haben gerade hatte in einer
Pressemeldung zum Bürgergeld zu diesem
Gesetzentwurf von Licht und Schatten
gesprochen der Punkt in der Rose man
eben angesprochen hat fällt er eher
unter Licht oder eher untersch naja also
erstmal finde ich es ein bisschen
zweifelhafte man auf der einen Seite
sagte dass man da nicht irgendwie
Spaltung herbei reden darf aber dann
sagt man will die Spreu vom Weizen
trennen also muss ja auch noch mal daran
erinnern dass hartz1-4 eben eine Reform
des Arbeitsmarktes war eine
Prekarisierung des Arbeitsmarkts mit
ganz vielen
niedriglohnensektor mit ganz viel
prekäre Beschäftigung wie Leiharbeit
sachgrundloser Befristung Minijobs ist
ja jetzt auch noch mal ausgedehnt worden
die minijob-grenze so dass eben gerade
Menschen die in Hartz IV sind wenn sie
eine Arbeit aufnehmen oftmals noch
abhängig bleiben von der Hartz IV
Leistung weil sie eben dann in die
Leiharbeit gehen und den Minijobs und
wir müssen diese prekären Arbeitsmarkt
bekämpfen so dass sich die Arbeit auch
wirklich lohnt dass man unabhängig
werden kann von den Leistungen und das
finde ich ganz zentral und wir werden
mehr hören gleich in der Debatte hier
die um 9 Uhr beginnen wird wie gesagt 90
Minuten dauert für einen ersten
Überblick wo die Streitpunkte so liegen
oder wo auch die Knackpunkte liegen
könnten kam jetzt leider keine Zeit mehr
gehabt über die Umsetzung zu reden das
soll ja in Stufen erfolgen so
offensichtlich der Stand der Dinge im
Moment erstmal die finanzielle Erhöhung
und alles weitere soll dann in den
kommenden Monaten kommen für heute
morgen vielen Dank Frau Tati und auch
Ihnen Herr Rosemann vielen Dank dass Sie
bei uns gewesen sind und schon mal einen
Einblick in diese Debatte gegeben haben
die wir gleich erleben werden vielen
dank ihnen beiden und wir meine Damen
und Herren werfen einen Blick in den
Plenarsaal und schauen ob sich da schon
ein klein wenig tut
Bundestagspräsidentin schon auf dem Weg
ist zu ihrem Platz wir sind kurz vor 9
Uhr und ihnen kann ich noch sagen meine
Damen und Herren dass es hier noch
weitere wenn man so viel
sozialpolitische Themen geben wird an
diesem Donnerstag im Deutschen Bundestag
beispielsweise wird erstmals beraten
dass Wohngeld plus Gesetz so heißt es
ist es soll ja ausgeweitet werden es
soll erhöht werden und es soll mehr
Menschen Anspruch auf Wohnwelt Wohngeld
bekommen und am frühen Nachmittag wird
diskutiert über die
energiepreispauschale für Rentner
Rentnerinnen und versorgungsbe
und jetzt sehen wir die
Bundestagspräsidentin und das ist für
mich das Zeichen reinzugeben in den
Plenarsaal
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
einen schönen guten Morgen die Sitzung
ist eröffnet
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung begrüße
ich einen
neuen Kollegen da sehe ich Ihnen im
Plenum daniel rinkert hat für den leider
zu früh verstorbenen Rainer Keller die
Mitgliedschaft im deutschen Bundestag
erworben herzlich willkommen und auf
gute Zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
als nächstes gratuliere ich der Kollegin
Luisa Licina Bode nachträglich zu ihrem
50 Geburtstag
alles Gute für Sie
und der Kollegin Rita schwarzlöhr Sutter
zu ihrem heutigen 60 geburtstag
da kommt sie
es sei gestattet am Geburtstag etwas
verspätet einzutreffen herzlichen
Glückwunsch
außerdem müssen wir noch eine Wahl
durchführen in das Kuratorium der
Stiftung vorn zur Finanzierung der
kerntechnischen Entsorgung gemäß
Paragraph 4 des
entsorgungsfondsgesetzes soll auf
Vorschlag der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen der Abgeordnete Harald Ebner als
Nachfolger für den Abgeordneten Stefan
Wenzel als stellvertretendes Mitglied
gewählt werden ich sehe sie sind
einverstanden das ist der Fall dann ist
der Kollege Ebner als stellvertretendes
Mitglied gewählt ich komme nun zur
Tagesordnung auf Verlangen der Fraktion
der cdu/csu wird heute im Anschluss an
die Gremienwahlen einer aktuelle Stunde
zum Thema Warburg Steuerskandal offene
Fragen im Buch der Akte Scholz der
Kanzler das Geld und die Macht
aufgerufen weiter soll
Tagesordnungspunkt 33
Buchstabe b abgesetzt werden ich gehe
davon aus sie sind damit einverstanden
ich sehe kein Widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen ich rufe nun auf die
Tagesordnungspunkte 7a bis 7c erste
Beratung des von der Bundesregierung
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
Änderung des zweiten Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer Gesetze
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes so wie
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
AFD mit dem Titel aktivierende
Grundsicherung statt bedingungslosem
Grundeinkommen Einführung von
Bürgerarbeit und Beratung des Antrages
der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem Titel
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt ausbauen 150.000
Langzeitarbeitslose in Erwerbsarbeit
bringen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und als
erstes hat das Wort für die
Bundesregierung der Bundesminister für
Arbeit und Soziales Hubertus Heil
eine sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bundesregierung hat sich mit der
Einführung des Bundes des Bürgergeldes
zwei zentrale Ziele gesetzt erstens wir
wollen Menschen
verlässlich absichern die in
existenzielle Not geraten sind und wie
schnell das geht haben wir in den
letzten zwei Jahren der
wirtschaftspandemie der corona-pandemie
erlebt wir haben erlebt dass
Solo-Selbständige die nie gedacht haben
dass sie mal auf ergänzende
Grundsicherung angewiesen sind darauf
zurückgreifen mussten und wir haben auch
erlebt dass Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer die geringe Löhne hatten
die in Kurzarbeit gekommen sind
ergänzende Grundsicherung brauchen
deshalb meine Damen und Herren eine
verlässliche Absicherung so
unbürokratisch wie möglich ist das Ziel
dieser Reform es geht auch darum dass
wir dafür sorgen dass Menschen die in
dieser existenzielle Not geraten sind
sich nicht sorgen machen müssen dass sie
auch noch ihre Wohnung verlieren und wir
wollen auch dass es ein Frage des
Respekt vor Lebensleistung das kleines
Erspartes nicht angetastet werden muss
und hinzu kommt auch dass wir dafür
sorgen werden dass die Regelsätze gerade
in dieser Zeit angemessen angepasst
werden die Regelsätze beim Bürgergeld
werden nicht mehr der Inflation
hinterherlaufen meine Damen und Herren
das erste Ziel der Koalition an dieser
Stelle mit dem Bürgergeld ist also dafür
zu sorgen dass die Menschen die Hilfe
benötigen die auf existenzielle
Leistungen angewiesen sind die auch
bekommen das ist ein Sozialstaatsgebot
ein schutzversprechen unseres
Sozialstaates dass wir mit dem
Bürgergeld erneuern zweitens
zweitens und das ist mir noch wichtiger
es ist dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht
nur existenzielle Not absichern sondern
dafür sorgen dass Menschen dauerhaft aus
der Not wieder herauskommen wir haben
eine Situation am Arbeitsmarkt die nicht
vergleichbar ist mit der von vor 20
Jahren als die hartz-iv-regeln
eingeführt wurden hatten wir
Massenarbeitslosigkeit in Deutschland
heute haben wir in vielen Bereichen
Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangel und ja wir
haben immer noch einen verfestigten
Sockel von Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit aber
wenn man sich anschaut woran das liegt
liegt es auch daran dass zwei Drittel
der Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen keine
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung haben
und das bisherige System führt dazu dass
sie dann hin und wieder mal in
Hilfstätigkeiten vermittelt werden das
Jobcenter sie aber oft nach einigen
Monaten oder Jahren wiedersieht wir
wollen den Menschen die Möglichkeit
schaffen ein Berufsabschluss nachzuholen
und wir sorgen dafür dass das auch
unterstützt und angereizt wird es geht
um dauerhafte Integration in
Arbeitsmarkt es geht um gute Arbeit
statt Hilfsjobs meine Damen und
und wir haben uns dafür
ganz lange damit beschäftigt wie wir das
System besser machen wir haben mit den
betroffenen Menschen gesprochen wir
haben mit den Kolleginnen und
kolleginnenden Jobcentern gesprochen die
übrigens der großartige Arbeit machen
wir haben mit der Wissenschaft
gesprochen
wir haben uns das Themen anderen Ländern
angeguckt und wir sind der festen
Überzeugung dass Ausbildung statt
aushilstjobs dass die Einführung des
weiterbildungsgeldes der richtige Weg
ist und übrigens diese Integration in
den Arbeitsmarkt auch dafür sorgen wird
dass wir ein Beitrag zur
Fachkräftesicherung in Deutschland
leisten meine Damen und Herren in den
letzten Tagen im Vorfeld dieser ersten
Lesung ist sehr intensiv diskutiert
worden schon das ist auch in der
Demokratie vollkommen in Ordnung aber
lassen sie sich eins ganz deutlich sagen
in diesen Zeiten in denen der
gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt bedroht
ist finde ich es persönlich unanständig
dass es einige politische Kräfte selbst
im demokratischen Spektrum gibt die
versuchen
Geringverdiener gegen Bedürftige und
Bedürftige geflüchtete auszuspielen das
gehört sich nicht meine Damen und Herren
sie müssen die Gesellschaft für
zusammenhalten
ja und das sage ich an die Adresse auch
der cdu/csu wir wollen als Koalition als
Ampelkoalition das arbeitslich lohnt das
Arbeit ein Unterschied macht und das ist
der Grund warum wir dafür gesorgt haben
dass der Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht
wird wir haben da nicht mitgemacht an
dieser Stelle
das ist der Grund warum diese Koalition
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge für
Geringverdiener gesenkt hat das ist der
Grund warum wir das Kindergeld erhöhen
das ist der Grund warum wir die
Gaspreise runterbringen den
Kinderzuschlag erhöht haben den
steuerlichen Grundfreibetrag gemacht
haben arbeit muss sich lohnen wer
Vollzeit arbeitet muss von der Arbeit
leben können aber bedürftige Menschen
gegen Menschen mit geringem Einkommen
auszuspielen das ist kein Beitrag für
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt das
gehört sich nicht in diesem Land meine
Damen und
wir müssen in dieser gesellschaftlichen
Lage die gesamte Gesellschaft im Blick
haben und nicht Gruppen gegeneinander
ausspielen und deshalb nochmal das
Bürgergeld ist kein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen das Bürgergeld ist eine
existenzielle Sicherung für Menschen in
Not und ich will übrigens sagen die
Debatte auch darf auch nicht dazu führen
dass Menschen sich schämen die auf Hilfe
angewiesen sind die auch in Anspruch zu
nehmen das dürfen wir in Deutschland
auch nicht zusätzlich
und dann wird ja einiges verbreitet ich
habe gelesen es seien bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen was für ein für nein das
ist es nicht das gibt einige die sich
das in Deutschland wünschen die
Koalition geht bewusst an anderen Weg
wir haben aber entschieden dass wir
einen Weg gehen indem wir nicht alle
Menschen die Not geraten sind und der
Generalverdacht stellen wollen zu faul
sein zu arbeiten das ist übrigens nicht
die Realität es gibt sehr sehr viele
Menschen ich habe mit vielen gesprochen
die unverschuldet in Not geraten sind
weil ihnen Schicksalsschlag
beispielsweise zwischengekommen sind es
gibt ganz hartnäckige Fälle in denen
braucht es Mitwirkungspflichten und
übrigens dann auch Leistungsminderungen
und die sind übrigens in dem Gesetz auch
vorgesehen bei akuten und wiederholten
meldeversäumnüssen und auch bei
dauerhaften Pflichtverletzungen aber ich
sage auch wir konzentrieren das Thema
Sanktionen auf die hartnäckigen Fälle
auf die es angewiesen sind der Geist des
Bürgergeldes meine Damen und Herren ist
ein anderer ist der Geist der Ermutigung
und der Befähigung und auch das leistet
einen Beitrag zum sozialen Zusammenhalt
und deshalb abschließend
die Einführung des Bürgergeldes zum
ersten Januar wird einer der größeren
Sozialreform seit 20 Jahren sein und ich
bitte Sie mitzuhelfen dass wir das auch
schaffen denn es geht nicht nur um die
Menschen die auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
indem wir damit ein Stück das Leben
leichter machen wollen es geht um den
sozialen Zusammenhalt deshalb sage ich
das Bürgergeld das bedeutet
Grundsicherheit für unser ganzes Land
und deshalb bitte ich Sie um
Unterstützung herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil mit seiner
Vorstellung des
bürgergeldgesetzes welche Vorteile ist
seiner Meinung nach bringen soll wir
haben den Widerspruch aus den reinen
schon gehört insbesondere aus der
Unionsfraktion wir haben es ja im
Interview auch angesprochen mehr Kritik
dazu jetzt mutmaßlich von Stefan Stracke
aus der Unionsfraktion
Deutschland sucht händeringend nach
Arbeitskräften die Zahl der offenen
Stellen befindet sich auf einem
Rekordhoch und es weit sind über 1,9
Millionen Stellen unbesetzt egal wohin
man blickt in der Gastronomie in
Einzelhandel im Handwerk in der
Industrie und gleichzeitig suchen 2,4
Millionen Arbeitslose eine Stelle
930.000 davon bereits seit Jahren
Aufgabe muss es jetzt sein die
Arbeitslosen deutlich besser als bisher
zu den offenen Stellen zu bringen wir
müssen alles dafür tun möglichst viele
Menschen dauerhaft den Arbeit zu bringen
das Bürgergeld wird dieser Aufgabe nicht
gerecht es ist eine verpasste Chance
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Union wollen arbeitslose Menschen
möglichst rasch und dauerhaft in Arbeit
bringen dabei wollen wir das fordern
bewahren und das Fördern deutlich besser
machen die links-gelbe Koalition will
die Grundsicherung vor allem besser
ausstatten sie will mehr Leistung und
deutlich weniger Mitwirkungspflichten
und weniger Vermittlung in Arbeit das
geht vollkommen in die falsche Richtung
zur Union wollen dass die Hilfe des
Sozialstaats denen zu Teil wird die sich
selbst nicht helfen können das ist auch
ein Gebot der Fairness gegenüber den
Steuerzahlern denn diese sind es ja die
mit ihren Steuermitteln die Leistungen
erst möglich machen und gleichzeitig
wollen wir die Grundsicherung so
weiterentwickeln dass Leistung und
Lebensleistung der Hilfebedürftigen
besser berücksichtigt wird arbeit muss
sich auch in der Grundsicherung lohnen
die Links gelbe Koalition blendet dem
Gegenüber die Erwerbsbiographie und die
Lebensleistung von Menschen aus beim
Vermögen und beim Wohnen durch eine
zweijährige Karenzzeit das ist eine
eklatante Gerechtigkeitslücke auch da
geht das Bürgergeld in die falsche
Richtung meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
wir wollen das Arbeitslose nicht zu
Langzeitarbeitslosen werden deshalb
müssen wir ab dem ersten Tag der
Arbeitslosigkeit alles dafür tun dass
die Hilfe überflüssig wird das
Arbeitsaufnahme gelingt und dazu braucht
es eine intensive Betreuung und Beratung
und passgenauer Unterstützung wir wollen
dazu ermutigen dass die Potenziale sich
entwickeln das neue Chancen mutig
ergriffen werden dass jede und jeden
geholfen wird einen Platz in der
Arbeitsgesellschaft zu finden damit
beruflicher Aufstieg und auch
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe besser
gelingen dazu braucht es Hilfe nicht nur
für den Betroffenen sondern für die
gesamte Familie Hilfe wie aus einer Hand
zusammen mit den Kommunen sorgt für
größere und nachhaltigere Erfolge und
die Jobcenter Mitarbeiter brauchen
endlich auch mehr Zeit um sich um den
einzelnen verstärkt kümmern zu können
würde am besten gelingen wenn man den
Betreuungsschlüssel verändert nichts von
all dem nichts von all dem wird in
diesem bürgergeldgesetz enthalten und
aufgegriffen das Bürgergeld ist hier
eine verpasste Chance bei der
Integration in Arbeit
und schlimmer noch
alle Erfahrungen zeigt dass besonders es
auf die ersten Monate in
Arbeitslosigkeit ankommt es sind die
wichtigsten Monate wenn man aus der
Arbeitslosigkeit in Arbeit kommen will
und statt besonders in den ersten
Monaten alles daran zu setzen um zu
aktivieren zu mobilisieren zu motivieren
ja notfalls auch mit bei
pflichtverstößen mit Leistungskürzungen
zur Antworten setzen Sie bei der Ampel
mit einer 6-monatigen Schonzeit sie
nennen das witzigerweise vertrauenszeit
genau das Entgegengesetzte Signal statt
Motivation setzen sie auf unverbindliche
Kooperation so kann der Weg aus Arbeit
nicht aus Arbeitslosigkeit nicht
gelingen
der Weg zurück in Arbeit wird deshalb
schwieriger weil die Ampel die
Vermittlung in Arbeit nicht verbessert
sondern sogar noch verschlechtert sie
kürzen die Mittel der Eingliederung nach
dem Haushaltsentwurf um 600 Millionen
Euro das bedeutet weniger Möglichkeiten
weniger Chance für Arbeitslose Fuß zu
fassen in Arbeit das ist schlicht fatal
was Sie an dieser Stelle machen
und statt zu kürzen wäre es viel
wichtiger mehr Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen denn die Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine brauchen jetzt unsere
Unterstützung die Mittelkürzung der
Ampel sind arbeitsmarktpolitisch falsch
und integrationsfeindlich noch dazu
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
sie sind die Regierung sie müssen ihre
eigenen Kürzungen verantworten Herr
Kollege und nicht hier auf die
Opposition verweisen wir wollen beim
fördern besser deutlich besser werden
und auf das fordern nicht verzichten zur
Wahrheit gehört ja dass über 95 Prozent
derer die sich in Arbeitslosigkeit
befinden mit pflichtverstößen mit
Sanktionen nichts zu tun haben weil sie
sich wie selbstverständlich an die
Regeln halten die Links gelbe Koalition
hat ja jetzt aktuell dafür gesorgt dass
wir im Kern ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen haben und zwar bis Mitte
nächsten Jahres ja hören sie hören nur
zu das bedeutet das hat vier Empfänger
nach der aktuellen Rechtslage jedes
Arbeitsangebot ja scheinen sie nur jeden
Integrationskurs jeden Deutschkurs jede
Weiterbildung folgend los ablehnen
können es ist erstaunlich dass die
Arbeiterpartei SPD genau ein zwei
solches zustimmen was noch erstaunlicher
dass die FDP dem zugestimmt hat diesen
sanktionsmoratorium
und jetzt wird denn mit dem Bürgergeld
eigentlich alles besser dafür mal
zitieren aus einem Interview vom
Johannes Vogel vom 22 juli in
Deutschlandfunk zur Tat Zitat es muss
wie vor dem Bürgergeld die Möglichkeit
der Sanktionen geben in dem Ausmaß wie
das Verfassungsgericht das zulasst alles
andere ist unfair Zitat Ende und genau
das ist es nicht was sie in diesem
Bürgergeld Entwurf machen sie bleiben
weit dahinter zurück was das
Verfassungsgericht in diesem Bereich
zulässt das zeigt auch einmal sie bellen
und am Ende nicken sie ab sie als FDP
sie sind der Wackeldackel dieser
Koalition meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
das Bürgergeld geht komplett in die
falsche Richtung es fordert nicht es
fördert nicht in die Maße wie es
notwendig ist und deswegen freue ich
mich auf die weiteren Beratungen weil
ich glaube dieses Gesetz kann nur besser
werden am besten mit einer Ablehnung und
vollkommen Neuaufsetzung dieses Gesetz
Stephan Strecke für die Unionsfraktion
mit einer sehr deutlichen Votum in
Richtung des bürgergeldgesetzes dass der
Bundesarbeitsminister hier zu Beginn
vorgestellt hat nämlich mit einer klaren
Ablehnung in dessen jetziger Form Beate
Müller Gemmeke aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen ist die nächste Rednerin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Herr Minister Kollegin und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Gäste
vor drei Jahren habe ich hier gestanden
und habe darüber geredet was ich bei
Hartz IV und bei der Arbeitsförderung
alles ändern muss jetzt ist es soweit
dass Bürgergeld kommt es ist gut dass
wir Hartz IV endlich überwinden
die Menschen brauchen natürlich soziale
Sicherheit wichtig ist vor allem aber
dass wir die Menschen die lange
arbeitslos sind unterstützen und stärken
sie brauchen neue Chancen und
Perspektiven und deshalb werden wir die
Beratung und die Arbeitsförderung anders
gestalten und genau dieser
Perspektivwechsel ist für uns beim
Bürgergeld besonders wichtig
Menschen sind Menschen sind aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Gründen
langzeitarbeitslos manche haben keine
Ausbildung andere haben gesundheitliche
Probleme und manchmal ist es einfach nur
das Alter auf diese unterschiedliche
Problemlagen aber hat Hartz IV heute
immer die gleiche Antwort und zwar die
Antwort heißt Aktivierung und genau
diese Logik diese verfehlte Logik werden
wir mit dem Bürgergeld verändern
und diesen und diesen Perspektivwechsel
möchte ich mit drei Punkten ganz kurz
verdeutlichen erstens wir schaffen
Augenhöhe und Vertrauen und Vertrauen
entsteht wenn die Zusammenarbeit in den
Jobcentern gut funktioniert und zwar
ohne dass jeder Brief gleich mit
Sanktionen droht und deshalb und deshalb
ersetzen wir die
Eingliederungsvereinbarung mit einem
kooperationsplan er wird gemeinsam
erarbeitet er ist niederschwellig er ist
verständlich er nimmt Rücksicht auf die
Vorstellung der Menschen denn nur wenn
die Erwerbslosen die
Integrationsschritte nachvollziehen
können wenn die Angebote für die
Menschen Sinn macht nur dann kann der
Weg in den Arbeitsmarkt zurück gelingen
zweitens
zweitens wir stellen Qualifizierung
Weiterbildung Ausbildung in den
Mittelpunkt und werden das auch
attraktiv machen und zwar mit einem
bürgergeldbonus und mit einem
zusätzlichen Weiterbildungsgeld in Höhe
von monatlich 150 Euro das ist uns ein
besonderes Anliegen denn Qualifizierung
ist Voraussetzung für eine nachhaltige
Integration in Arbeit
und drittens die
arbeitsdrittens finden Sie
Arbeitsförderung muss tatsächlich zu den
Menschen passen bei manchen
Langzeitarbeitslosen funktioniert
Vermittlung andere brauchen zunächst
Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung und
wieder andere die brauchen erst einmal
geschützte Räume und soziale Teilhabe
und diese Unterschiedlichkeit müssen wir
gerecht werden und zwar mit
individuellen Angeboten und deshalb
werden wir den vermittlungsvorgang
abschaffen und wir werden den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt entfristen denn Arbeit
bedeutet soziale Kontakte Wertschätzung
Anerkennung und gesellschaftliche
Teilhabe das ist wichtig das ist wichtig
denn hier geht es um die Würde der
Menschen
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen sind lange
arbeitslos weil die Arbeitswelt nicht
inklusiv ist wenn nicht wenn die
Menschen nicht hundertprozentig passen
oder Unterstützung benötigen dann haben
sie häufig keine Chance und deswegen
hilft eben Aktivierung nicht und dabei
geht es eben auch nicht um die Kritik an
der Arbeit und am Engagement Engagement
der Beschäftigten in den Jobcentern
sondern es geht um die gesetzlichen
Grundlagen und die werden wir mit dem
Bürgergeld
bürgergeldgesetz verändern und davon
werden die Langzeitarbeitslosen
profitieren aber davon bin ich
davon bin ich
davon bin ich zutiefst überzeugt denn
das Bürgergeld hat einen anderen einen
wertschätzenden Blick vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die afd-fraktion
gerrituy
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die afd-fraktion setzt den Bürgergeld
einen eigenen Antrag entgegen weil wir
nicht glauben dass das Bürgergeld
funktionieren wird es ist nichts anderes
als ein aufgeweichtes Hartz IV und das
hat schon nicht funktioniert so war es
beispielsweise nicht möglich aus dem
Millionen her der
hartz-iv-leistungsbezieher auch noch 100
oder 200 Personen für den
Koffertransport an deutschen Flughäfen
zu rekrutieren dabei sind und hören Sie
gut zu gut 8 Prozent der Menschen
überwerbsfähigen Alter bei uns im Land
Hartz IV Empfänger das ist ein sehr
großer Anteil Menschen die von der
Arbeit der Steuerzahler Leben allein die
Krankenkosten für diese Gruppe einzig
ihre Familie betragen über 20 Milliarden
Euro im Jahr
in Dänemark Schweden oder Belgien
hingegen liegt der vergleichbare Anteil
bei gerade mal zwei Prozent also einem
Viertel da muss man sich schon fragen
was diese Länder besser machen
deswegen möchte ich mit Ihnen kurz
dorthin schauen allen Ländern ist gemein
dass schon Vermögen zunächst mal also
vor dem Schonvermögen das eigene Kapital
aufgebraucht werden muss und diese
chancevermögen liegen in der Regel unter
5000 Euro in jedem Fall deutlich unter
den deutschen 60.000 Euro und eine
angebotene Arbeit muss im Grundsatz auch
angenommen werden
in den Niederlanden muss man zu dem
aktiv in der eigenen Wohngemeinde selbst
Arbeit suchen andernfalls bis zu drei
Stunden Fahrzeit protok annehmen oder
man muss umziehen sonst wird die
Sozialhilfe gekürzt in Italien gibt es
das bürgereinkommen für Erwerbstätige
nur wenn man den letzten zwölf Monaten
seine Stelle nicht gekündigt hat und
auch kein anderes Familien Mitglied dies
getan hat sonst wird die Sozialhilfe
gekürzt in Frankreich werden beim Bezug
der Mindestsicherung Wohnungen Autos und
Schmuck gegengerechnet in Österreich
muss man seine Auto gleich verkaufen
wenn es nicht für den Beruf benötigt
wird ein Arbeitsweg von insgesamt zwei
Stunden ist Zumutung zumutbar wäre
Schulungen nicht besucht eine
Wiedereingliederungsmaßnahme ablehnt
oder zu wenig Eigeninitiative zeigt
riskiert zwei Drittel der Leistungen
asylberüchtigte müssen zudem innerhalb
enger Fristen einen wertekurs und
Sprachkenntnisse auf a2-niveau
nachweisen und in der Schweiz
schließlich muss ich jeder
Leistungsempfänger zügig nach einer
neuen Arbeitsstelle umsehen und dafür
und Bewerbungen hinausschicken bei
Arbeit gefunden hat muss die Sozialhilfe
wieder zurückzahlen
unser Nachbarn achten also streng darauf
dass Ihre Mindestsicherung nur als
vorübergehende Hilfe genutzt werden kann
dadurch sind sie wesentlich
erfolgreicher bei der Reintegration in
den Arbeitsmarkt nicht so bei uns in
mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle schaffen
es die Jobcenter nicht die Arbeit
Chancen der Arbeitslosen zu erhöhen sagt
die interne Revision es mangelt ihnen an
Zeit und Kontaktmöglichkeiten und nicht
selten auch an der Motivation der
Leistungsempfänger denn so sagt der
Sozialexperte bei huschen für Hartz IV
so Wörter genannt für darf ich für
Hartz-IV-Bezieher mit Familie ist aber
rechnen kann er ist die Stütze zu hoch
sie haben mit Hartz IV deutlich mehr als
sie Einkommen aufgrund ihrer
Qualifikation beziehen würden
und auch
handwerkspräsident wollseifer fürchtet
bearbeitet ist zukünftig der Dumme meine
Damen und Herren wir wollen nicht dass
er Recht behält und deshalb unser Antrag
für eine aktivierende Grundsicherung die
Leistungsempfänger zügig wieder in
Arbeit vermittelt dankeschön
aus der afd-fraktion verweist in ihrem
Redebeitrag auch noch mal auf den Antrag
zum Thema Bürgergeld den die AFD hier
eingebracht hat nächster Redner ist Jens
portrino aus der FDP-Fraktion der ist ja
Sprecher für Bürgergeld lieber
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Versprechen
unseres Sozialstaates ist es diejenigen
aufzufangen mit einem sozialen
Sicherungsnetz die nicht in der Lage
sind mehr für sich selbst sorgen zu
können dabei liegt die Betonung bewusst
auf können ein Sozialstaat dem es aber
nur darum geht finanzielle Bedürftigkeit
zu fordern ist nicht an sich sozial
sozial ist der erst wenn er auch
Menschen dabei unterstützt sich durch
eigene Arbeit heraus aus der sozialen
Bedürftigkeit befreien zu können das ist
aber kein Widerspruch Solidarität und
der Ansatz Menschen aus einem in den
Arbeit zu integrieren ist kein
Widerspruch sondern das gehört zu beiden
zum Grundsäulen des Sozialstaates
und gucken wir doch mal ins Gesetz rein
sie haben gesagt der Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel das wird das Bürgergeld
nicht vollkommen beseitigen können wir
haben so viel offene Stellen und auf der
anderen Seite so viele Menschen und
Arbeitslosigkeit Hartz IV hat das auch
nicht geschafft ihr System was die
verteidigen heute und was die so
beibehalten wollen was die nicht
verändern wollen hat dieses Problem auch
nicht gelöst
ein Beispiel wieso das nie gelöst wurde
sind die absurden Regelungen zu den
hinzuverdienstregelungen im
Hartz-IV-System wenn Menschen anfangen
mehr zu arbeiten die Motivation haben
sich Stück für Stück herauszuarbeiten
mit einem Job dann ist in die Regelungen
so dass Menschen die aufstocken zum Teil
es weniger haben wenn sie mehr arbeiten
gehen der Anreiz ist genau falsch
herumgesetzt der Anreiz muss so sein
Menschen die mehr arbeiten haben auch
immer mehr in der Tasche und deswegen
passen wir diese hinzuverdienstregelung
ich weiß dass sie das im Kern ja sogar
teilen sie teilen ihre Form der
hinzuverdienstregelungen wir passen die
an ersten Schritt an oberhalb der
Minijobs wir wollen nicht dass Menschen
im Minijobs gefangen werden sondern dass
sie sich in
sozialversicherungspflichtige
Beschäftigung heraus aber und das werden
wir die hinzuverdienstregelungen genau
da anpassen dass ein Schritt der
Leistungsgerechtigkeit für unser Land
und die jungen Menschen die selbst in
der Bedarfsgemeinschaft aufwachsen die
dürfen in Zukunft wenn sie eine
Ausbildung machen wenn sie zur Schule
gehen ihre Nebenjob behalten es ist eine
absolute eine Absurdität der des
Leistungsprinzip das junge Menschen die
sich etwas hinzuverdienen dürfen davon
nichts haben es setzte der Hartz IV sagt
zu diesem jungen Menschen gehen nicht
arbeiten bleibt im System streng dich
nicht an und diese Botschaft kehren wir
um bei das setzt sich im Kopf von junger
Mensch und fest seine weitere wichtige
Änderung beim Bürgergeld und ich möchte
jetzt noch etwas sagen sie haben uns
dafür kritisiert für den Haushalt ich
habe mir noch mal die Anträge angeguckt
diese bei den letzten
Haushaltsberatungen gestellt haben zum
bmas-haushalt sie haben gefordert die
jugendberufsagenturen die Mittel dafür
zu halbieren die jungen Menschen den
Arbeitslosigkeit sind den wollten sie
die Mittel Weg halbieren sie haben
gefordert die berufliche Integration und
Beratung von Zuwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt die Mitte zu halbieren sie
wollen nicht die ukrainischen
geflüchteten den Arbeitsmarkt bringen
sie wollten die Mittel halbieren sie
haben die fachkräfteoffensive im
Bundeshaushalt die Mitte wollten sie
ebenfalls halbieren Schulen sie nicht so
als wenn sie Menschen in den
Arbeitsmarkt integrieren wenn das ihre
Haushaltspolitik ist das sind die Fakten
das waren ihre Anträge das sind nicht
unsere Anträge und wenn sie und wenn Sie
Herr Stracke und ich finde das wichtig
und wir teilen das Gebot wir teilen doch
das Gebot dass derjenige der arbeiten
geht stets mehr haben muss als der der
nicht arbeiten muss da sind wir uns doch
einig sind sie aber in Kern wirklich
gegen die Regelsatzerhöhung Herr Stracke
sie haben auch gesagt dass die
Mehrleistungen vollkommen an der
Realität Vorbeigehen Herr witteka die
CDU-Politiker der gleich spricht hat bei
Twitter aber kommentiert nach dem
Koalitionsausschuss wo das beschlossen
wurde richtiger Impuls regulleistungen
zu erhöhen wenn die Inflation auch
massiv steigt muss gemacht werden ich
war mit Julia Klöckner bei Unter den
Linden ich ziehe die zitiere sie sie
können sich vielleicht erinnern wir sind
nicht gegen eine Regelsatzerhöhung davon
gehe ich aus dass die Regelsatzerhöhung
auf gut 500 Euro kommen wird wenn wir
sie nicht wenn wir uns den
hartz-iv-warenkorb angucken die
Lebensmittel um 17 Prozent steigen dann
ist es richtig den Regelsatz zu erhalten
es ist unredlich auf der einen Seite in
der öffentlichen Zeit zu sagen wir
wollen die Regelsätze erhöhen und auf
der anderen Seite mit den Ängsten der
Menschen in der Energiekrise das ist der
Grund wieso Menschen momentan das Gefühl
haben die vorher auf der Stelle
gestanden haben jetzt zurückfallen mit
diesen Gefühlen zu spielen das ist das
Geschäft von Populisten ist eine Frage
Beweglichkeit in dieser Debatte bei den
Fakten zu bleiben und die Fakten sind
und das wissen sie sie werden ebenfalls
zu einer Inflationsanpassung sonst sagen
Sie es öffentlich dass sie dagegen sind
dass sie den Regelsatz bei 450 Euro
lassen wollen und zum Fakt gehört auch
die Sanktionen werden zum allergrößten
Teil beibehalten bis zu 30 Prozent kann
bei meldeversäumnissen sanktioniert
werden bei Pflichtverletzungen ist das
Maximum was das Bundesverfassungsgericht
zulässt und dann geht es um die
vertrauenszeit die sie kritisieren in
der vertrauenszeit können
meldeversäumnisse wenn jemand nicht zu
einen Termin kommt ebenfalls
sanktioniert werden das sind 75% aller
Sanktionen das ist der Großteil der
Sanktionen der weiterhin auch in der
vertrauenszeit ausgesprochen wird
kritisieren sie uns dafür was wir machen
kritisieren sie das Bürgergeld aber
hören sie auf auf Grundlage falscher
Fakten in der öffentlichkeitsstimmung zu
machen es ist brandgefährlich es ist
brandgefährlich sie haben in
Niedersachsen das Ergebnis gesehen das
Ergebnis haben sie in Niedersachsen
gesehen und das Ergebnis sich dort es
braucht eine Oppositionspartei die die
Regierung treibt es braucht eine
Oppositionspartei der Mitte die uns
kritisiert aber kritisieren sie doch
wirklich uns für das was wir machen und
erfinden sie keine Fake News das ist
gefährlich ob Regelsatzerhöhung oder
Sanktionen hören sie auf mit diesem
Geschäft hören sie auf von
sozialturismus zu sprechen ein
gefährliches Geschäft was sie machen
Jens leutine der Sprecher für Bürgergeld
in der FDP-Fraktion mit
doch einem heftigen Angriff jetzt auf
die Unionsfraktion zuvor hat er auch
Widersprüche verwiesen zwischen der Rede
von Stefan Stracke hier im Parlament und
früheren Anträgen der Unionsfraktion und
da kriegt er jetzt viel Applaus für
diesen Redebeitrag aus den Rhein der
ampelfraktion nächste Rednerin wird sein
Jessica Tati aus der Linksfraktion wo
sie Sprecherin für Arbeitsmarkt und
Sozialpolitik ist und da sie Treue
Zuhörer und Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
sind haben sie heute morgen schon bei
uns im Interview gesehen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Minister Heil
eines muss man ihnen lassen das ist das
erste Gesetz zur Änderung von Hartz IV
das nicht alles noch schlimmer macht
sondern einige Verbesserungen auf den
Weg bringen
das alle Leute die neue Leistungen
beziehen eine zweijährige Karenzzeit
haben in der die Kosten für Wohnung und
Heizung voll übernommen werden das
unterstützen wir das hilft aber all
denen nicht die jetzt schon in Hartz IV
sind und die aus dem Regelsatz Monat für
Monat bei den Mietkosten draufzahlen
müssen eines der größten Probleme in
Hartz IV und diese Menschen die lassen
sie weiter im Regen stehen das müssen
sie doch jetzt ändern
gut ist dass Schüler Auszubildende und
Studenten zukünftig mehr vom
selbstverdienten Geld behalten dürfen
endlich setzen Sie damit die langjährige
Forderung von Sozialverbänden
Betroffenen und auch der Linken um
aber
dieses Gesetz ist keine Überwindung von
Hartz IV wie es ihr permanent behauptet
wird eine Überwindung von Hartz IV würde
zwingend mindestens drei Dinge erfordern
eine Geldleistung die für ein
bescheidenes aber angstfreies Leben
ausreicht das Recht auf aus- und
Weiterbildung um damit wieder am ersten
Arbeitsmarkt fußfahrten zu können den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt ausbauen für
diejenigen die ohne ihn keine Arbeit
finden können passiert das mit ihrem
Gesetz sorgen die 50 Euro für ein
angstfreies Leben nein sie fummeln
einfach so lange am Regelsatz herum bis
das rauskommt was der Minister wollte
das ist keine echte Erhöhung des
Regelsatzes sondern ein reiner
Inflationsausgleich der ist absolut
notwendig aber damit kommen sie
bestenfalls
bestenfalls ihrer Pflicht nach dass die
Leute noch essen kaufen können das in
der Strom nicht abgedreht wird und dass
sie im Winter nicht in einer dunklen
Wohnung sitzen müssen reichen 50 Euro
mehr die Wahrheit ist die Leute bleiben
genauso arm wie vorher denn das was sie
nicht angehen ist das jahrelange
kleintricksen der Regelsätze die Leute
standen doch schon vor den krassen
Preissteigerungen mit dem Rücken zur
Wand und deshalb fordern wir Sie auf
berechnen Sie die Regelsätze binnen
eines Jahres neu beteiligen sie die
Betroffenen beteiligen sie die
arbeitsloseninitiativen die
Wohlfahrtsverbände und die Tarifpartner
und bis das passiert ist braucht es
einen Zuschlag wir sagen monatlich 200
Euro mehr gegen die Inflation gegen
Armut und soziale Notlagen
jetzt zur Weiterbildung von Menschen in
Hartz IV sie reden da ja sehr viel
drüber vor allem wie unfassbar wichtig
Ihnen das wäre und was machen sie dann
sie kürzen eiskalt die Mittel dafür im
Bundeshaushalt was nutzen all ihre
schönen Worte wenn es kein Geld für die
Umsetzung gibt Menschen in Hartz IV
nehmen am allerwenigsten an
Weiterbildungen teil und das wissen sie
und trotzdem kürzen Sie einfach immer
weiter und wenn wir schon beim Kürzen
sind alle in der Ampel reden so stolz
vom sozialen Arbeitsmarkt wie
unverzichtbar wie erfolgreich und wie
großartig er noch sein oder stimmt auch
die geförderten Arbeitsplätze bringen
Menschen in Lohn und Brot mit
Arbeitgeber mit Arbeitsvertrag und mit
selbstverdientem Geld sie wollen den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt mit diesem Gesetz
auf Dauer fortführen super Sache wir
unterstützen das bloß blöd das auch
dafür real fast keine Mittelmeer im
Haushalt sind und sie den sozialen
arbeitsmarktdefaktor kaputt sparen
korrigieren Sie das ansonsten ist das
die größte Verarsche auf dem Rücken von
Langzeitarbeitslosen sorry frau
Präsidentin Herr Minister dann müssen
Sie auch den Schneid haben sagen Sie
hier klipp und klar das
Langzeitarbeitslose keine Priorität mehr
für diese Bundesregierung haben wir
fordern 150.000 Jobs im sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt und die Finanzmittel die
dafür notwendig sind
sind im übrigen ihre 150.000 die sie in
der letzten Legislatur versprochen haben
Minister heil